[Applause]
first we want to start the news today
officially by making sure that we reach
out to all of our veterans today and say
thank you
this whole show is in honor of you
and we appreciate you for your service
and dedication to this country and as
our beauty week continues here at the
show we are thrilled to celebrate and
honor four very special veterans who are
here with us today let's meet them
[Music]
my name is beth geese i live in cannon
falls minnesota i'm suzanne i currently
live in alexandria virginia my name is
janae sergio i served eight years in the
navy my name is anai maldonado i live in
prosper texas
i moved to the united states in 2004 and
being a veteran to me it means a lot
just because there's so much more that i
can give back to this country that has
given me so much i joined the military
from a homeless shelter i didn't really
see a future for myself so i decided to
give the navy a try i joined the air
force in 1992 because i wanted a better
life for myself and my girls
since the pandemic started i've been
working from home i'm not taking very
good care of myself i think i've had
this haircut since oh my gosh at least
30 years my girls are basically telling
me that all they ever see me in is jeans
or a sweat or t-shirt everyone in my
office thinks that i just have the most
boring style in the world i've been
working on myself and i just want the
outside to match how i feel inside i
need to find myself again so that i can
get rejuvenated for my husband and be my
best self for my family
and some of their friends loved one and
family is here so i would like to know
katie give me one thing that we need to
know
about your sister beth
she keeps accomplishing things over and
over and uh now a superintendent and
just making the world a better place by
giving everything to those kids that
she's in charge of well thank you for
sharing that thank you
all right mark and chiago what is the
one thing that we need to know about
your wives anna e and janae
okay good
and so my wife she's got such a giving
heart she's always given to everybody
else and often times you know
it's a detriment to herself and this is
just gonna really kind of amplify that
that beautiful soul that she has and you
know show it on
uh janae's uh
not just like a beautiful person on the
outside she's even more beautiful on the
inside uh
so she's very deserving of all that and
you know i'm really happy for
well i i'd like to ask crystal what is
one thing that we need to know about
your mom suzanne so my mom she's my
biggest superhero she's always taking
care of everybody else putting herself
last so thank you so much she deserves
it
i can't wait to see the reveal that
being said i do have one very special
thing to say is that they're in the
hands of one of our druid crew chris
appleton
um who does the hair of oh let's just
say jlo
uh kim kardashian
um katy perry part of her ariana grande
and her so at least they're in really
good hands when it comes to their hair
and you're literally with the best
right hey drew so we're underway here
things are fast and furious and it's
changing i'm here with janae and we've
just been talking a little bit about
changing their look up i've got two tips
for you guys when you're thinking of
changing your hair at home and going
into the salon the safest way to get it
right is to take an inspiration picture
so you're both on the same track the
second tip is to make sure it suits your
face shape we're all about face shapes
and honestly things sometimes look good
on one person but don't look so good on
the other so you really need to work
with your face shape find out if you
have a round or square face or even
heart shape there's many face shapes out
there and there's a style to suit all so
make sure you pick the right one welcome
back the ladies makeovers are going
great it's all in process i'm so excited
to see i am here with the stylist to the
stars who also happens to have the best
heart chris appleton
hi guys
thank you all right um chris you are so
busy helping these incredible veterans
i mean i've done this show a few times
with you i always have fun it's always
an amazing heartfelt experience but this
one was a real tearjerker and i can't
wait for you guys to see them i want to
do everything with you for the rest of
my life let's do it i want to be with
you forever chris all right i'm so
excited to see the new looks and ladies
please come out
[Music]
oh
my
gosh
[Applause]
you guys were already so beautiful that
being said walk us through
what you did with these beautiful women
i think here we wanted we wanted to go
for something a little shorter and a
little fresher and kind of lighter and
sometimes you can kind of cut away with
the
ears with a style you know it's not
always about keeping length as you can
see before it was kind of quite dark so
we wanted to make sure it suits the skin
tone and we wanted to soften the skin
tone that's why we added those lighter
highlights
i think you look so beautiful how do you
feel most important amazing and we
learned so many things from chris so
this is just amazing well chris really
thinks head to toe he does he does
we should talk about these shoes we were
talking about the nude heel and i think
what's really important about this is
it's actually given the appearance of uh
a bit of a taller finish which i think
you did give us a swirl
let's go you ready
the best husband um brad and her sister
katie are here in the audience what do
you guys think oh amazing looks so
beautiful so beautiful
so she
deserves this so much thank you
okay thiago um did you want to say
something um to your wife janae yes she
looks absolutely
stunning i love it
you look really beautiful today was so
much fun to work with
we decided with the length just to
simply add more layers now this is a
great tip for any of you guys out there
with fine hair so you guys know that
layers can be a bit of a problem but you
know it's always that thing of like
trying to create volume layers are very
helpful for that but there's nothing
worse than the spindly ends when it gets
really thin and you end up kind of you
know making your own haircut look
thinner than it already is so we wanted
to create more face framing layers so
really we just work with the face
framing around the front so it was more
about kind of opening up this front
shape here so she had the shorter layers
here and it just generally give the hair
a little bit more volume but keeping the
weight at the bottom
your hair looks so thick and luxurious
thank you all right let's move on anna e
and suzanne
um chris tell us what you did there we
made the color lighter so it was a
little bit softer and as you can see
before previously it was quite dark and
we felt like it was a little heavy on
the skin yeah so we wanted to give it a
slightly lighter feel but without it
being blonde or anything too far away
from you know what a natural base was
that she also has a few extensions in um
i don't know if you guys can notice but
it's longer now
don't forget that extensions are not
just about length really we didn't
necessarily want to create
so much length it was more about texture
and volume how do you feel right now
sexy
i do i really do
okay mark um what do you think of your
wife um annie's look
um
amazing this is just spectacular you
guys
amazing i thank you guys so much
crystal uh how are you liking it what
are you thinking she looks gorgeous
she's glowing
you know you can see previously her hair
was quite short around the front so
again we worked with your extensions
around the front it lasted around six
weeks and it was just really to kind of
fill it out this look in particular was
just all about the shine so it was about
getting that real glossy high shine give
us a little swish
she wanted that kind of rich expensive
glossy looking hair
you look so beautiful how do you feel
most importantly i feel amazing
beautiful i feel like i'm 30 again so
thank you
[Applause]
you guys just all look wonderful and if
you feel it then that is the most
important and i just want to thank beth
janae annae and suzanne for your service
thank you for helping us celebrate
veterans day in such style and in such
meaningful ways always chris oh
absolutely listen this is what it's all
about all right well thank you everybody
for this beautiful day thank you for
your support your dedication your time
your energy thank you so much for
choosing to spend your time with us we
make this show for you so take it with
you
[Music]